how's Gomez's be the joy of being a girl
gamer and today we're gonna play some
frozen mini games where do we begin
where do we be else a frozen fluid Oktar
yes all right here we are Elsa oh oh oh
this phone out and taking down my bias
elation the wind is howling now this oh
it is howling oh no Elsa is out in the
snow you're gonna catch a cold
can we talk about this beep man alright
well check the body temperature sniff it
sniff it
sniff it out sorry alright there we go
oh she called us [ __ ] ma'am that is some
ass coldness jack nasal spray ill that's
disgusting
yeah that's right sniff that [ __ ] it's
actually cocaine open up wide [ __ ] she
bit off the spoon I don't have to play
sorry
never wanted to die a slow death as much
before Princess Anna Thanksgiving Day
makeover
oh man that's the great title of a game
please oh god what is that
[Music]
why me look at that face where are your
eyes
[Music]
those are your eyelids what are those
what do I do it point there a point here
I don't I don't know what the at it I
don't know I don't know what you want I
don't know what you want okay I got the
tweezer if I twenty-five-year-old can't
figure this out then how the hell are
all these young kids gonna do it what
what am I missing
I can't I can't I can't figure it out I
can't I just [ __ ] can't oh oh well
this game has this what this is not the
game I wanted right I clicked on another
game I can't escape I cannot for the
love of anything wholly understand what
I'm supposed to do with the tweezer in
this game you brothers need to help me
out here alright okay baby Elsa hair
salon injury what the [ __ ]
I don't know huh huh why I can't oh hey
don't cry a chair have a [ __ ] llama
that's right and a good chew Gucci
stupid [ __ ] now let's cut that hair
stop prying your bag share have a
[ __ ] there you go you're gonna look
fabulous when I'm done with your [ __ ]
oh god I cut her [ __ ] face how what
is
what is frog with our face stop crying
please for the love of God here have a
magnifying glass that'll do the trick
oh god what's in there Elsa what have
you done in there you know what is that
oh my god what is that what is that oh
god it's [ __ ] music - like holy [ __ ]
oh now we do stitches that was that
other thing then oh my god why don't you
oh god what is that
what is that ah I lived a girl life I
live oh don't want to deal with this
anymore I've done enough [ __ ] my
days god damn alright here have some
drugs right now that's appropriate yep
after one week okay
now what she needs to make over here
there you go that's that that was it
okay my favorite part was the final part
that was a great game was rated please
kill myself alright let's see what you
bro said you should you have to pull out
the hairs above the eyebrows I have to
pull out the hairs above the eyebrows oh
my god oh my god where did the arrow
point okay fine you know what I did it
now what what is this oh god another
that was the pimples it's the pimple
squeezing machine wonderful now scrape
off her face oh great we dope okay
uh-huh
oh god what happened to her face she's a
demon on the inside I knew it people
take games like GTA and say violence all
the violence is bad for them I take
games like these and if people play this
[ __ ] that's the real [ __ ] up people
that are born from it like these are the
games that needs to be banned [ __ ] that
game [ __ ] look look at the look at the
thumbnail that's the thumbnail for that
game you [ __ ] lied okay not okay with
baby Anna did we really need a baby at
the baby and what the [ __ ] did you do
baby Anna I don't know what you do in
your spare time but I'm honestly quite
concerned baby Anna
it's Halloween themed - okay I I no no
no no no no no no no I'm not no not
[ __ ] playing that one no one [ __ ]
night oh okay
LSAT foot doctor it said Elsa foot
doctor
great great feet you have there Elsa oh
it sells a hand doctor now okay you
touch some weird [ __ ] Elsa I don't know
why I don't know why but I'm not gonna
know I'm not no no sick of those [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] frozen frozen frozen nose
problems this game won't launch but
it'll and all that is thank you yes yes
this is this is what we all wanted so
someone sat down and was like frozen
nose problems yeah that the whole game
that game we should make I can't
huh I'm
[Music]
they just never [ __ ] end do they they
just never end
Oh God Elsa okay all right so two people
here have raided this game good and good
good Elsa no right well frozen elsa
gives gives birth okay
all right here we are at the hospital
weird dude
oh she she needs an IV right oh my god
she's dying
oops baby pretty sure the baby's dead
Elsa I don't know what else to do for
you oh I guess I'll rub the belly a
little bit oh god that face looks like
the baby died again better rub that
belly better rub it off it's like Taylor
Swift old me here has some mustard gas
oh oh that up that it get it in fluid
flow in okay why not I can't I can't no
what
baby else have a Christmas make out we
need mmm-hmm what is she doing what are
you yeah yeah I
[Applause]
I know they're not made for 25 year olds
but I just can't comprehend it what the
[ __ ] am i doing what what is that what
is that supposed to be
what summon please please explain to me
and why is this Santa has a shower head
oh my god and there's a baby really need
this here have a phone number that yeah
huh-huh so many emotions today god
there's so there's so many there's so
[ __ ] many frozen games oh my
Elsa dentist she's crying a lot well I
probably would too if my face look like
that what do you do trying to do trying
to surgically insert grills or like I
don't cry outside this will only hurt a
lot no what am i doing all right well I
guess oh nice nice just pulled them all
out you know why not just pull them all
out I need to get that some I by the way
oh nice
Oh much better really honest honest to
god that that looks that looks great
some may say you look like a demon from
hell elsa i say there the tears are
still there okay done great game damn
now scared of my life that's great thank
you
all right you know what that's quite
enough that's quite enough thank you
thank you for sharing this with you bros
I don't think I could have done it
without you my finger watching hit the
sky come read today for more Oh God and
live a live a nice life somewhere in
peace
you
[Music]